القاهره والفنان عمر زهران يسعد هالمسا يا
استاذ عمر اهلا بك انت وندى الافطار اهلا
اهلا جميل على النيل
تعرف الكرم المصري الكرم المصري ومعانا
النيل العظيم ومعنا يعني لوجه الحسن
حضرتك معنا يا استاذ عمر طبعا ده شرف كبير
لينا
وحضرتك دلوقتي
بتشارك في عملين من الاعمال الترند جدا
محققه مشاهدات عاليه جدا وجدل كبير جدا
على السوشيال ميديا وناس متابعاهم بشكل
كبير وبتصورهم في نفس الوقت
اولا اول سؤال احنا عايزين نعرف ازاي انت
بتفصل بين الشخصيتين وبين دي في حقبه
زمنيه ودي حاجه تانيه واللي عمالين
مختلفين تماما طبعا اسمحيلي بس احيي
النجمتان الجميلتان
سهام ونادين وتحياتي للشعب الجزائري
والشعب الفلسطيني وان شاء الله رمضان
القادم نصلي في القدس جميعا باذن الله
ونفرح بانتصار الشعب الفلسطيني باذن الله
يعني فيما يتعلق بمشاركتي في العملين هو
الفصل بين الشخصيتين ما فيش شك انه كان
شيء صعب وخاصه ان ده عمل تاريخي وده عمل
عسكري ولكن اول ما بدخل الكتيبه والبس
الافارول وابدا اقرا الكلام حتى في اثناء
في كواليس العمل طوال اليوم يعني كنت يعني
عايش الموضوع جدا وعايش الشخصيه ومش منفصل
عنها ومش عامل تليفونات خاصه ومش بقدر
اهزر مع حد واتكلم مع حد
الجيش المصري يعني قائد مصري في سره
الباتا في شك انه الدور كان صعب لانه دور
ضد الشعب المصري ودور واحد بيقر المصريين
وبيجندهم في حرب للاسف
الاناقه لهم فيها ولا جمل ولكن
الاستيعابي للشخصيه من خلال جلسات العمل
اللي حصلت مع الاستاذ خالد يوسف مفيش شك
انها ساعدتني كتير
ومسلسل كمان سر الباتع يعني هو متاخد من
روايه عميقه جدا ومؤثره جدا وناس بتحبها
جدا
هي الروايه طبعا خالد يوسف طوارها وعمل
مسلسل بشكل مختلف انت شايفه ازاي هو اولا
مش هذهع سر اعتقد انه خالد صرح بيه قبل
كده انه ده حلم عند خالد من 20 سنه انا
وخالد اصدقاء جدا والحقيقه ان هو كان عنده
حلم سر الباتا حتى كان عنده اختيارات
لموضوعات ربما تكون جماهيريه اكتر لكن سر
الباتع هو انت عارفه المجنون بتاع الروايه
نفسها بيتكلم عن عظمه هذا الشعب والباتع
دي اللي هي يعني بتحمل معاني عديده
ومتعدده جوه هذا الشعب اللي جواه اصرار
وسر كبير جدا جدا بيخليه زي ما كان بعض
جمل في في الروايه بتقول هو في العمل
الفني ايضا انه انه صعب انك تغيري هويته
وصعب انك تهزم يه حتى وان بدا ليكي لبعض
من الوقت انك قد ملتي من هذا الشعب لكن
طبعا على العكس تماما شعب قوي وقادر يواجه
كل المحل بكافه اشكالها وانواعها والوجه
كل الاعداء
معك نادين وسهام لو حابين يعني احنا
قاعدين وسامعين للجلسه وسامعين للنقاش
والاسئله بس كمان احنا يعني بطلع لنا كم
من سؤال يا ندى معلش ناخذ اذنك
ههه تفضلوا طبعا طيب يا استاذ الانتقادات
طالت ممثلين وفريق العمل بشكل عام انه
بيقولوا لك بعد الاكسسوارات والملابس اللي
شفناها انه غير ملائمه للحقد الزمنيه اللي
وقعت فيها احداث المسلسل شو تعليقك يا
استاذ عمر
والله يا استاذه هو ما كانش ما كانش
ظاهرها في طوال المسلسل هي اعتقد خطا واحد
فقط وده كان وارد في افلام عالميه والعظيم
يوسف شاهين لما عمل تحفته الخالده الناصر
صلاح الدين ما قدرش يدخل بسبب ساعه ظهرت
في المجاميع اللي كانت موجوده لكن انا
اللي عايز ادوف لحضرتك حاجه مهمه انه
احيانا ظاهره
بسيطه جدا او زهيره بسيطه
تبعدك عن المعنى الحقيقي او الهدف الحقيقي
للعمل اللي هو هدف عظيم بل اهداف فكره ان
انت النهارده بتخلقي حاله وعي شديده لدى
الشعب لدى الشعب ولا لدى اجيال عديده من
الشباب بكفاح هذا الشعب المصري عبر العصور
وازاي خالد قدر يربط بان العدو واحد العدو
زمان كان اجنبي والنهارده العدو للاسف بقى
منك من جواكي وبصراحه شديده جدا جدا بدا
بيحارب وبيهدم فطبعا انا بحييه على هذا
الربط اللي حاول انه يضفره المخرج المتمكن
والمبدع خالد يوسف اما عن الاشياء
المتعلقه بالسوشيال ميديا دي حاجات بتحصل
عشان التسالي وعشان الناس تبقى
بتنبسط يعني مع هذه حضرتك طبعا اخد بالك
انه
نعم
اتفضلي شرطه السوشيال ميديا هي اللي دايما
الرابط بين ادوار حضرتك خلال الفتره اللي
فاتت حتى في الكتيبه 101 هي القياده
القائد قائد كتيبه جيش قائد المماليك في
الممر
هو الحقيقه يعني الحمد لله ده نعمه من عند
ربنا
يعني الناس بتحس باني عندي قدره على
القياده وانا بفضل ربنا الحمد لله حتى لما
في شغلي كمخرج وعملي كرئيس لقنوات يعني
كنت محقق الى حد كبير بفضل ربنا وبشهاده
الجميع قدر من الاداره الجيده يعني دي
نعمه من ربنا باحمد ربنا عليها وبحمد ربنا
ان انا وفقت يعني ان انا زي ما حضرتك
تفضلت وقلت انهم الدورين مختلفين كل دور
في حقبه مختلفه بس الحمد لله كنت الى حد
كبير
بحمد ربنا يعني بس الناس بتتساءل برضو على
السوشيال ميديا دائما ان هم هل ممكن بعد
التجارب دي يشوفوك في انواع مختلفه او
الوان مختلفه من الادوار التمثيليه طبعا
غير ان حضرتك عملت اكيد اعمال متنوعه
كمخرج بس كممثل ممكن يشوفك مثلا في
الكوميدي في بالتاكيد طبعا برحب بس في
حدود حفاظي على الايمج اللي انا صرعته قبل
سنوات طويله كاعلامي ورجل كان عندي برامج
لها اهداف معينه والناس كانت بتنتظر مني
دايما كل حاجه بقدمها انها تحمل قيمه فانا
طبعا ما عنديش مشكله خالص بس المهم انك
تكوني بتقدم
ما بينشبع منكم ومن هالجلسه الحلوه ولكن
انتهى الوقت
من القاهره
مراسله مسائل عربيه مدح كازيه